la table à temps la table après c
qui fait j'étais demande et on m'a dit
oui parce qu'il commence active à la
prendre dans ses discours et rentable
alors si je peux prendre la table tu
m'as dit oui
vous l'apprenez je vous ai demandé où va
la prendre je croyais que vous at war
c'est pas pour l'apprendre alors porter
quoi vous allez vous éclatez vous me
dites j'ai plein de la table ah non mais
s'il est sérieux repoussa parce que j'ai
pas envie de rigoler aujourd'hui c'est
un mauvais jour
mais moi je croyais que vous prendrez la
table pour nous at war d'accord c'est
pas prendre dans ce pays je peux prendre
la chose quand même à la chaîne peinture
d'accord merci
non non non écouter à liège guillemins 4
après je me suis dit lâche es tu m'avais
dit le chef bien sûr et écoutez vous
payez
tu m'as dit oui ou pas ouais mais pour
prendre un verre ouais mais tout le
monde embarque 3 la table finale et cela
ah bon
elles sont lourdes en coulisse maintien
alors tu en mets à sa place non c'est
trop lourd mais sa place à
la chaise quand même on n'est pas à
l'abri c'est pourquoi
j'allais prendre à table vous allez
prendre la voulait pas mon pantalon
aussi sait quelle taille arrêter de
présenter parce que moi j'ai pas envie
de plaisanter d'accord je plaisante pas
et alors laissé la table et répartissez
le grand père en avait quand même ici
y'a pas de
[Musique]
ckoi garçons quartz et aujourd'hui c'est
une mauvaise pourquoi une journée qui
verra compliqué là bas vient ensuite
accompli là bas et on peut prendre quoi
chez toi
[Musique]